Hello everyone, my name's Dan and I
am the CEO and co-founder of Mary
Technology.
Um, so we're a legal tech
firm based in Sydney, but now with a global
presence, and we help law
firms automate, uh, document
review. That's a
major challenge for large language
models, and I wanna talk to you today about
how Mary's trying to solve that.
Just before we start, can I ask how many
people here are
uh heads of legal operations
inside of uh large enterprises
or
uh have your own law firm? Yeah,
OK, great, cool.
Hello? You can't do those.
Um, so here's the problem, uh,
large language models,
uh, even with retrieval augmented generation
or agentic frameworks,
are not fit for purpose for legal dispute
resolution workloads.
There's a number of problems. I'm gonna talk about 4
today, the first one being the
training problem.
So what do I mean by the availability of training data,
so The sorts of
data that we work on every day
for law firms and legal teams
that deal with disputes,
they're very sensitive, and so
this sort of information isn't available publicly,
and you certainly can't collect and train on
that data when it contains sensitive
information from law firms' customers
or your internal employees.
The second challenge is that there isn't a single
right answer to tell a
large language model to sort of trend
towards, because there's always at least
two sides
of a matter.
And so you can't just say, hey, here's the right answer
and try and move and
probe towards that. You have to
include and understand all of the potential
available narratives and correct answers depending on
which side you're representing.
The second problem,
and maybe the biggest one, is that large language
models are compression machines.
That's what they do really well, and I'm just
going to talk to you a little bit about some of these
stages of compression.
So. The first thing
that a large language model does when it receives a document
is it turns,
ultimately turns that page into an image.
And then if that image has words on it,
or an image, even if it's actually
just a picture, it will still ultimately convert
that into text.
But particularly in legal documents where you actually have
lots of words there,
it's gonna take away and remove
some of that nuance,
legal nuance and important meaning that
may be present there, so things like handwriting
or a small note on the side.
Once it's turned that
document into text,
it then ultimately turns into tokens and then
into embeddings, then a contextual
compression, and ultimately something
that's capable of uh chunking
and summarization.
Each layer of that compression
removes meaning,
and it's that meaning and nuance that's so important
to
law firms and anybody trying to understand a dispute
or facts, which is sort of
the core of a dispute,
well. Here's
what they're really good at though, we're not saying large language models
are bad, we're actually saying they're really, really good,
but they're particularly good at being
generally capable. So they handle
a massive range of tasks,
they scale across massive corpuses
of documents,
and they generate fluent, plausible
text without.
Deep preprocessing.
So they're generalists and they're really
good at that, and so you can, as you can probably tell,
uh, this slide was written by an LLM
it's done its lovely emojis
and done a very good job of, of telling me what
the slide should say.
The third problem,
facts are not in the uploaded
data. This is a bit of a strange
one and something that
might take a small amount of
explanation,
but the facts are what is at the core of
a legal matter or a dispute.
So I'm just going to give you an example.
Here's a fact that might be present
inside of a document.
It gives the date, which is wonderful,
and then it says A. Smith
reported an error.
So here's a few of those challenges about
why you can't just extract this piece of data
and assume that it's ready
uh in its current state to be used
for downstream
processing using AI.
What if there's multiple people within
that corpus of documents called
A Smith? One could be Alice,
one could be Andrew,
but. In order to make this a
useful or meaningful act, you actually
have to understand which A Smith that is.
Uh, and by just using a large language model, you can't do
that. Uh, we're in the US
today, so
where we're from,
Australia, um,
these two dates are completely separate, so
this could be the 5th of,
uh, January, February, March, or, yeah, there
we go, 3rd of May.
So you've gotta try and
understand what is the context of this matter, so that
you can actually say, great, it's probably this date.
In this matter, is a reported error on this date
even important?
That's obviously more to do with context,
and so maybe this isn't a relevant fact
for you to understand and dig into more.
It's also fragmented.
How many times is this particular fact
mentioned
throughout all of these documents, and do they
potentially conflict with this fact or support
it? And finally, provenance,
what kind of document did it come from?
If this is, for example, a primary
document,
um maybe it's come from.
Somebody detailing what a CCTV camera
saw or
or if it's from hearsay from somebody's statement that
was given to
a police officer, for example,
all of those have different meanings as to how
relevant and meaningful they are when
related in court or in a litigation
process. Here's
another example, this is actually from my co-founder
Rowan's medical documents,
and there's a couple of challenges in here
that I'll actually hopefully show you how Mary,
our, our, our platform deals with it just a little
later. But the one thing I'm gonna point
out here is, and this is incredibly common,
PT.
What it actually means here is patient.
Now, what would happen if you put this fact into
a large language model?
Well, it wouldn't understand that it's talking
about Rowan.
Who is the person it's actually referring to,
or rather the patient itself, so you need
to actually converge and
correct things like this piece of information
so that you can actually leverage that information
later when you're trying to use it
within a fact or rather
document review process.
This is a more
drawn out example of
something that a large language model
would do incredibly poorly
in comparison to, to a system that is
designed and built to support
litigation workflows and the
document review that's as low
fault tolerance as law.
So imagine I've written a letter,
um, within it, I don't
write my name, and I don't say who
I'm writing it to.
And I detail out
a crime I've committed, uh, but
I don't necessarily say it in the simple
fact that, say, you know, I didn't, I
didn't, don't put that I stole that car, I say it
in some colloquial way,
um. The challenge for a large language
model, if that document is placed in between
4000 other documents,
if you were to ask a large language model,
did Daniel steal a car,
well, it wouldn't ever be able to say yes,
because Daniel's not mentioned, and I didn't
say that I stole a car, and
I also don't say who I've written it to.
What Mary, or rather what
any tool that's going to do this type of work.
In a document review process in law
needs to be able to do is
do things like look at the handwriting of that letter.
Is that handwriting present in any of the other
documents? Can we understand who actually
wrote that?
Also, maybe I wrote on it a date
when I went to the park.
We need to be able to understand that in this other document over
here, Daniel said that he went to
the park on that date and then try and
understand that, hey, actually, maybe we can draw a conclusion
here and say, brilliant,
maybe you should review whether or not
this is Daniel, because we've got some supporting evidence.
So that's an example of where large language models
just fall short
in this type of work.
And the last problem
is that even if I did all of that fact
extraction perfectly.
That's not really what lawyers and legal
teams need when undertaking
an investigation.
They actually need to feel really confident uh
about those facts and the narrative that
they're going to present
on their client's behalf.
Or for their company.
So here's an example.
Is anybody a lawyer?
OK,
well, We've got one, brilliant.
So this is just a, a, an example,
hopefully that gets you thinking as to why this is so
important, but that it's uh an
exercise, the perfect letter of demand.
So imagine a large language model spits
out to you and says, here's a perfect
legal document,
whatever it is, and I've done the work for you,
I've gone through this entirely massive corpus
of documents. I've extracted all
of the facts, I've reviewed what's
relevant in the context of the case, and
I'm now going to give you the perfect document, in
this case,
a letter of demand.
I can assure you it's the ideal
uh letter to file, it's supported with the perfect
evidence, it's in your
template that you normally use, all of that good
stuff, please now go and file it with the other
side or with the court.
Would you, would you go and file that?
That's the correct answer, good.
Uh, you can't because you need to ultimately
you have an obligation to whoever it is that
you're representing, but more importantly, you, you
have a responsibility to make sure that you're confident
about doing that,
uh, with the action that you're taking.
And so, unlike a large language
model that is perfectly built
to receive a question
and then deliver a correct answer,
what's required in
this type of work,
in this
document review and litigation
workflow, is something that, that doesn't
know what the question's going to be,
yet can understand all of the facts and
give you all of the potential narratives
for you yourself to review and
verify and become confident in.
So how do you fix all of these
problems?
Well, in a way that large language
models simply don't like,
because it's incredibly uh
process heavy and it's not a
generalized task, it's very specific. And
the first thing you've got to do is treat facts
as first-class citizens.
So in the same way that a large language model says,
the most important thing to us is
having an incredibly efficient
embeddings model.
A fact review platform needs to have
the best fact model and say,
right, great, we're gonna take those facts and we're gonna process
them and make them,
uh put them through this manufacturing pipeline that's
incredibly heavy and deliver to you something
that you can rely on, and then ultimately,
verify, which is why you need a world-class
review and verification experience.
This is where the lawyer or the,
the team representing or trying to undertake this
investigation, this is where they go to review the
facts that have come out, build their narratives,
and more.
And finally, and this is maybe
the one piece that I think is
missing uh
from what I've spoken about before, is
you need to then take this layer
of facts.
That you can feel confident about and
pipe it through to these downstream
AI applications,
so things like OpenAI or
any other unified interface,
you can just pipe them in there and and have them
working. OK, so I've
got a short video to show you how we've solved
some of these problems.
As a lawyer, when you receive a case.
Your first goal is to get the facts straight.
But this is never straightforward.
It means digging through endless emails,
PDFs and records, splitting
documents, cross-checking dates,
piecing together a clear timeline.
It's slow, it's manual, and
it can take anywhere from hours to days
before you've even started the legal work.
We call this fact chaos.
But what if
the moment a case landed in your inbox,
everything was set in motion?
We could take the attached documents in the email
or find uploaded documents in the tools you
already use,
then scan and process them.
The messy bundled files could be split
into clear,
structured documents.
They could be categorized, renamed,
and seamlessly organized back into your workflow,
exactly where you need them.
But what if organizing documents was just the start?
What if we could unblock you completely,
so you can get started on the real legal work?
We can pull key entities from every document,
names, businesses, and their role in the
case,
giving you instant insight into exactly
who matters.
Find and capture significant dates
when events occurred.
Get a concise case summary, distilling
the entire matter into a few clear paragraphs.
Identify gaps that need assessing, detect
possible data leaks, build a timeline
of events, and extract any other key
details relevant to your case.
Then bring all these insights together
in a single dashboard, so anyone
can get a firm grip on a case in minutes,
even if they've never seen it before.
Delve deeper with generated chronologies,
surfacing only what's most relevant to
your case. Invite experts to work
alongside you and your colleagues in real time
and draft directly into the tools you
already use.
Because MRI connects with your existing systems,
it adapts as new evidence,
events, and documents emerge, keeping
your case aligned every step of the way.
When the facts are clear,
decisions are faster.
Back to chaos.
Solved
Um,
OK, so just to, just to conclude
what I'm trying to get at there and hopefully
that you could see in the video,
it requires a novel approach.
And
interestingly, we couldn't use what most
people
can, which is retrieval, augmented
generation, or agentic workflows to
just go into the documents and extract the
facts that are meaningful and present them
to a user.
So that's what I'm sort of
saying up here, we can't just use good enough, it
has to be.
Brilliant.
And so we built a fact manufacturing,
processing pipeline,
where, where we extract every event, entity,
actor,
issue, loads of other stuff. Ultimately imagine a
fact as like an object,
where it has lots of metadata underneath it that
allows you to build relationships and
construct a case, almost as a
digital
case as a an object.
So it will then do things like
tell you whether or not a fact contradicts with another.
And then the important part here is that
every
piece of that metadata underneath that object
has to be explainable.
So we'll surface and expose any
rationale
if we make a single decision. If we make a decision, we
tell you a date, we're going to tell you how we got to that date.
If we're going to tell you something that's relevant, we're going to tell you how
it's relevant.
Only after producing that high quality fat
layer do we then use these
more traditional or or not traditional,
very new technologies, but the more
standard technologies such as RAG and ergentic
frameworks,
and the result is a persistent
auditable fat layer that you can rely
on both in the platform itself when you're
doing that investigation
or downstream when you want to pipe that
information down and use it when you're drafting
or other associated legal tasks.
So I'm just gonna show you just very briefly what the platform
looks like for a single fact, just to
highlight that challenge before when I spoke
to you about
patient.
So you can see here, there's a fact
at the top.
So you can see that there's a date with a time, and
it's talking about a chap called Rowan McNamee
is reassessed, swelling to right bicep
remains. You'll notice that that's an incredibly summarized
and concise fact.
That's because that's what lawyers need, they need to be able to have a
look at all of these facts because the majority
of them won't be relevant.
So if we just
zoom in on, I've, imagine I've pushed my mouse
over to the right-hand side and I've hovered over
that relevance, and it's gonna tell me, the
entry focuses on a separate medical
issue. Now bear in mind, I know a lot of my examples
have been in personal injury, but this is
for employment, or any type of
law you can do this with.
But in this particular case, personal injury. So it's gonna
tell me why this isn't relevant.
But then I'm able to dive deeper
if I think it might have some relevance.
You can see I can pull up the actual
document on the exact page
and space where that fact has come from, and
I can also rely on Mary to give
me more rationale as to how it came up with this
fact and where there's more uh details
that I can replace
the fact with if I want more information. But you'll
notice that this handwriting's terrible. I mean, well, it's
pretty good handwriting, um, but
yeah. It works on unstructured
data primarily rather than things like
contracts, where all of the
information is very easy to get out, we have to focus on the documents
that are really difficult.
But the reason I bring this up is because if we have a look in that
document, that's where it's from, PT
or patient.
Well, we don't just rely on that, and this is just one of those
elements where we correct the fact as we
go through that pipeline.
We say, Rowan McNamee, so that
ultimately when we pipe this fact down into another
downstream AI capability, it
knows it's looking for Rowan McNamee, so when you say,
hey, did Rowan ever go into a hospital
with this, it can say yes and be
confident, and you can go directly back to where
that was found.
So, just, just quickly on
on where we, where we're at in our journey, um,
we work with many of the largest firms now in
Australia, and including ANO
Sherman, who's one of the largest law firms in the world,
both here and over in the UK and everywhere
else. But we're, we're bringing on more firms
every single week.
Across all of our customers, we
have achieved a 75 to 85%
reduction in time spent on this, probably
the biggest bottleneck in litigation, which
is document review. It's where so much of the
time is spent, it's where so much of the cost is accrued,
and we're reducing it significantly.
And overall, we've achieved a 96 out of 100
MPS score.
People really love using Mary because
this is one of the most difficult, annoying, frustrating
jobs that you can do as part of this
process, and so people love it.
Um, here's just, I'm just gonna leave this up on
the screen briefly.
Uh, it is a little bit Aussie, um,
but this is, and I, I've had to redact the name, which
is why there's a little dot here,
um, but that's what one of our customers has
said, uh, about how they use Mary.
So, I'm, I'm, I, I'm open it up to questions
if anybody's got any, but, um, that's
Mary technology and, and how we're building this
fact layer.
Any questions?
No?
Cool. Thank you